they come in they say nice clean dining
room with the kiosks uh to order for the
food but they get it to go um uh so they
are originally alarmed by not seeing a
dining room we do have a cylinder for
people to wait for their food uh but you
know it's really it's new but in a lot
of our dining rooms that we have uh all
of our customers are getting our food to
go as well as it is already so you know
this is for the on the go uh on the
mobile ordering on you know this is just
a grab and go kind of location uh which
really caters to you know most of our
consumers that we serve in most of our
restaurants today
uh and as we came out of code with you
know
we were 100 drive-through uh we only
only got back about ten percent of our
uh our consumers eating in our dining
rooms uh you know we went from a
delivery business of being you know one
or two percent of our business to now 15
our drive through went from being 60 or
70 to now it's you know 83 of our
business a lot of people are coming just
to see what it's about we have a lot of
our competitors coming in and working
and saying oh wow these guys are cutting
edge maybe we need to look at doing
something similar to this but it's been
great it's it's great operationally for
our teams to run because it simplifies
our business uh it helps us to serve our
consumers even faster late at night so
uh this is a new it's one of a kind uh
but i don't think it's going to be
one-of-a-kind long because i'm sure that
you know based on what we've seen
already that we're going to be doing
more of these locations because we can
fit it on a smaller smaller pad cater to
more customers and really get a good
taco bell out there
like everybody wants i'm sure that
there's going to be a lot of people
adapting if you know our business is
ever changing uh but we're going to talk
about diversified restaurant group has
always been cutting edge from this
restaurant to our cantina on the strip
to some of the containers we have on the
beach in california as well too so we
like to think of ourselves as
trendsetters and
people coming out coming after us
because
we want to be known as the best